s'ils
[Musique]
saluent vous l'avez vu dans le titre
aujourd'hui je reçois un autre mentalist
sur la chaîne viktor vincent vous avez
déjà vu plusieurs fois sur ma chaîne en
gros je vous raconte vite fait il est
passé pour m'apporter son bouquin peu ce
qui sort un roman il a reçu les cinq
premiers exemples du coup je suis est ce
qu on en profiterait pas pour essayer un
truc genre est ce que les personnes qui
travaillent avec moi qui sont habitués à
voir du mentalisme à longueur de temps
est ce que tu peux toi les mentalités
vous allez voir ça dans cette vidéo et
on va papauté aussi en même temps bref
bienvenue dans cette vidéo où mon équipe
va se faire mentaliser par un autre
commentaire
[Musique]
alors moi évidemment je te connais
depuis des années donc c'est assez
facile pour moi de savoir qui tu es
présente toi pour ceux et celles qui ne
connaissent pas ou il donc c'est une
bonne question ça c'est très
introspectif mentalist sur scène à la
télévision en librairie ce que tu fais
un peu ce que tu fais mais avec avec
plus de place pour les pour les
histoires dont le récit haut puis j'ai
écrit un roman c'est incroyable c'est le
premier mentalist que je connais qui
sort un roman inchangé bernard werber
qui m'a dit c'est dommage que les
mentalistes sortent pas de romans parce
que vous savez gérer le suspense les
histoires les révélations et
l'impossible et du coup oui l'idée
l'idée c'est un petit peu ça parce que
effectivement sur scène on essaie de
conduire le public dans des fausses
pistes ou voilà et là c'est génial parce
qu'on peut vraiment faire ce qu'on veut
monter dans ce qui tient à un moment je
vais leur faire croire que ça et puis
finalement non et puis à priori ça donc
on peut s'amuser avec des mouvements
comme ça puis président super sale
zeller c'est un thriller un thriller
psychologique à passer pas un polar n'y
a pas d' enquête on se dit qu'il ya tué
qui c'est plutôt la relation entre un
maître et son élève alors à m ghizzoni
c'est évidemment et son élève une
relation très toxique ou l'un va devenir
le reflet de l'autre jusqu'à une
destruction complète quand on a un
maître de la manipulation et qu'on va
apprendre de lui mais forcément c'est
manipuler donc on voit un peu comment ça
ce fonctionnement
non
bon on teste quelque chose j'imagine
qu'avec fabien tu as l'habitude de subir
quelques petites mentalisation on essaie
un petit jeu tout simple juste pour voir
comment tu fonctionnes sûr mais la pièce
je la prends tu mets ça dans ton dos tu
me la pièce dans une des mains et tu
mets tes mains de cette manière comme ça
face à moi donc l'appeler ci soit ici
soit là forcément comme tu as regardé
cette main dans la ville est là et je
vois que tu culpabilises d'entre eux
montrent effectivement aller tuer
droitière oui en général on commence par
la main droite je le dis on va
recommencer tu vas avoir envie de
remettre la pièce en un droit de faire
esprit de constance sauf que maintenant
j'ai dit ça tu vas avoir envie de la
mettre là mais tu vas voir que
finalement tu vas quand même faire ce
pour quoi tu mélanges
nazis m'a dit tu sais ton choix c'est
son choix tu mélanges de mélange des
ménages tu mets des mains de cette
manière et quoi qu'il arrive tu ne
réagis pas comme ça
voilà donc soit ici soit là par esprit
de constance c'est là tu n'as pas pu
faire autrement montre à la caméra
effectivement alliés la maintenance est
rentré dans une boucle psychologique
c'est à dire qu'on peut refaire ça 10 x
20 x 30 x tu mettras toujours la pièce
dans la main gauche même si tu ne veux
pas le faire aux pédales de l'asile
recommence non je prends mon temps en
temps je dis tu veux pas le faire je
crois quand même
[Rires]
donc tu ne voulais pas la mettre là mais
tu la mise quand même mon fils
parce que c'est la boucle chico logique
on peut faire ça dit x 30 x ça marchera
toujours comme ça dingue qui arrivent
pas la mettre à gauche comme si je
pouvais pas rêver coup tu vois là encore
aucun autre et encore un autre je vais
essayer une dernière fois en juillet
pour voir plus et on doit les conserver
mais de là tu vas tu vas te dire que tu
encore plus envie de la mettre à ma
gauche parce que tu te dis à une file
dernière fois pour que le métro
est ici encore une fois voilà c'est
comme ça c'est parce que j'y arrive pas
il paraît qu'on a tous amis bras écrire
entre l'avoir en tête sont deux lignes
de l'idée de base est le faire c'est un
temps considérable en fait pendant une
tournée j'avais écrit un scénario de
long métrage et puis j'avais fait lire
ça mon éditrice de l'époque et pénalités
à cela pourrait en faire un beau livre
j'ai rencontré un éditeur et puis le
problème c'est que je n'ai pas le temps
donc on a signé un contrat mais sans
date de sortie et donc du coup est
arrivé tu sais il s'est passé un truc en
2001 avec le premier confinement je me
suis dit voilà que ça y est maintenant
j'ai le temps d'ailleurs j'avais
tellement le temps que plutôt que de
reprendre le scénario j'avais écrit je
les ai laissés de côté et j'ai
recommencé une nouvelle histoire que
j'ai écrites directement sous forme de
roman c'était formidable j'ai très bien
vécu ce confinement parce que ce qu'il
avait comme des ouvertures et
l'ouverture et c'était quelque chose de
différent jeu j'ai pu faire ce que je
n'ai jamais le temps fais toi tu écris
donc premier roman j'imagine que tu as
la découverte de l'organisation
travaille trois heures par jour pas plus
sur l'écriture par contre je peux lire
je jauge arrête tu veux mourir un joli
joli ce que j'ai écrit ou je lis
d'autres choses parce que comme ça ça me
nourrit mais je suis pas organisés comme
toi de ça s'est fait un peu de manière
dans le train un peu retourné un peu à
peu chez soi je suis pas sûr qu'une
méthode pour écrire un livre la méthode
qui te va et qui fait que dans le livre
tu là où on fait en ce qui est important
c'est faire les choses qui nous
ressemblaient pas faire c'est ça ben
c'est toujours envie d'écrire les livres
qu'on a envie de lire nous mêmes
j'espère que d'autres personnes quand
même on le dira oui j'espère
[Musique]
pauline j'imagine que tu te fais
mentaliser constamment parfois bien
c'est tout le temps pas tout le temps en
tout cas ils le cachent
manipulent sans qu'il sache est ok moi
je veux juste pour ton plaisir c'est pas
pour manipuler l'esprit c'est juste pour
le plaisir tu penses ed on va en garde
je comprends que ça tu vas mettre le nez
dedans tu maintenant c'est un peu ça
fait du bruit c'est sympa tu regardes
ici pendant qu'on est sur le numéro 5
mélange plusieurs fois pour vérifier que
c'est toujours différent évidemment
cesse regarder
vérifie encore plusieurs fonctions
aujourd'hui tu comptes très satisfaite
tu peux t'arrêter tu regardes tu me dis
quand c'est bon ok tu à compter de
demain ainsi c'est forcément content de
vinci sera prononcé le chiffre sur
lequel tu étais tu laisse rien
transparaître
1 2 3 4
vous d'être horrible on a vu que ça
s'est crispé la sueur numéro 5 donc ça
le petit sourire me dis que c'est
effectivement un immense intérêt on
commence mais non
tu regardes je regarde pas c'est bon
[Musique]
on serre les dents à partir de numéros 5
d'encore cinq noms 6 alors juste après
alors oui c'est ça ok on est en tournée
je veux
tu regardes gros mélange encore
1 2
5 6 dt sur cinq avant avant mais comme
je te demandais de rechange et était
encore sur cinq ce que j'ai vu qu'il
avait pas de satisfaction study me suis
toujours mais moins c'est ce que tu te
dis là tu es sur le double 3 mon avis le
2 3 le 3 je suis encore remet l'enjeu
par deux
touches plus que tu regardes c'est bon
quand un deux trois
voilà bah écoutes je travaille bien je
laisse faire voilà je vais les embêter
d'autres personnes et j'ai pu me
contrôler mais je sais pas ce qui a
bougé dans mon visage au pas mais j'ai
fait de mon mieux pour me contrôler il
est très fort alors là tu m'as parlé de
la méthode de l'écriture comment toi par
contre tu as eu envie d'écrire un roman
l'envi en fait tu sais que tu sais dans
les spectacles que je fais j'ai toujours
laissé beaucoup de place or ici il ya
toujours beaucoup d'histoires et tout ça
donc en fait pour mac est un roman c'est
comme écrire un spectacle vraiment pas
vraiment de différence et dire que c'est
c'est la même chose c'est logique c'est
naturel je me suis pas dit est ce que je
suis illégitime pas parce que j'ai
essayé de faire c'est de créer vraiment
des ambiances un roman d'ambiance l'idée
c'est de mettre quelques petites touches
pas accroché au public précise ok on est
là mais après le public va se construire
aussi tout ce qu'il ya autour tiens donc
c'est bien s'est dirigé diriger le
regard et après est ce que j'aime dans
la lecture c'est qu'on peut on peut
imaginer ce qu'on imagine on quelqu'un
qui découvre apparition il le lit mais
évident ce mec fait des spectacles je
vais le voir sur scène est ce que eux
ils vont être complètement surpris de te
voir sur scène où est-ce qu'ils vont se
dire tiens j'avais déjà un peu perçu le
style de l'auteur non je pense qu'ils
sont très surpris parce que c'est un
thriller
c'est par une très sombre donc les
spectacles sont tous publics là on est
dans quelque chose - tôt public donc que
les journalistes qui me disait mais non
je vous prenez pour un gentil je vois
vous êtes quelqu'un prêt sont là je suis
quelqu'un de pas sombre du tout mais le
roman les est ce que toi s'adapte permis
d'explorer cette haute face et de la
créativité qui est un peu le sombre
comme dans ce large lui beaucoup de
livres comme ça donc en fait j'ai créé
entre guillemets le le roman que
j'aurais que je très volontiers ma
bibliothèque dont je me suis pas
vraiment posé la question mais je me
sens pas du tout frustré sur scène
d'être d'être un gentil
ce fut un gentil avec chargeur que oui
match parfait amour mais
d'après bon écrire des
tu vis aussi la vie un peu de des
personnages que tu que tu inventes l'air
dans les personnages qui sont horribles
mais que je les aime je les adore ce
sont des choses épouvantables mais voilà
moi j'aime depuis toujours été du côté
des méchants dans le film
d'environnement donc là je viens c2mi
gens qu'ils affichent un endroit une fin
en soi
ok pourquoi on chuchote on sait pas
c'est pas parce qu on est en train de
voler quelque chose
non
le wiki non c'est déjà croisé plusieurs
fois oui parce que trop avec fabien
depuis très longtemps mais je n'ai
jamais fait de truc quoi que ce soit
jamais dans cette expérience allez j'ai
délivre ici ce sont les mots livre avoue
sur les sorciers les comme en tout cas
j'ai cependant d'un livre ici et puis on
va choisir une page au hasard est ce que
tu peux me le numéro des pages c'est
juste en bar murs des pages en bas tu me
le dis stop où tu veux
là une page en plus une période moins là
précisément page ici on est quelle page
142 ouvrir le livre la page 142 s'il te
plaît oui celui-là et puis tu caches tu
montres par la caméra non plus puis tu
regardes bon j'ai pas la première ligne
si un mot qui t'intéresse dans la
première ligne la page 142 tu ne dis
rien à haute voix
un mot à mot le premier mode la page 2
e
ok d'accord pur ferme est-ce que tu mets
ton doigt comme ça ok concentre toi sur
la première lettre du mot fait réciter
l'alphabet d'exploit dans sa première
lettre qui pensent stop quant à lui pas
et on doit quand je t'ai dit de ne pas
piller et en doctorat envie de le faire
douter à l'alphabet l'envers z y xwb ut
srq p&o
nml car j y agf edc b a donc on a vu la
crispation un petit peu c'était vers la
fin à mon avis oui b ou c quelque chose
comme ça c'est certain
c est ce que tu veux dire trois mots qui
n'ont rien à voir avec ce mot voiture
chaussures oui
d'accord est ce que c'est un tu ne
penses pas un mot qui définit un objet
je pense que c'est plutôt quelque chose
d'abstrait dans mon ça cela tu m'as
donné que trois mots concret donc on est
un extrait hockey est ce que tu peux me
donner trois autres mots ah oui
blues un portail et un cornichon oui
c'est vrai que fabien m'avait dit que tu
étais un peu spécial une avait dit il
m'avait dit ok ok
capable non ça c'est un adjectif
capacité capacité exactement ses
capacités ou voilà c'était quelle page
sur ces rentes 242 capacité de pas citer
la vois très bien mais ouais parce que
votre cornichons capacité cornichons
capacité d'accor
merci beaucoup victoire de venus pour
faire cette vidéo tu es chez toi sur
cette chaîne mais je te donnerai pas les
codes d'accès d'accord peut-être pas
d'économie devine reste bravo pourtant
les bouchées assez impressionné par sa
je vous met encore une fois un lien vers
le livre la description et un lien vers
son spectacle encore en tournée oui pour
assez longtemps avec des dates qui sont
pris aux folies bergères je crois oui
aux folies bergère du 20 au 30 décembre
de cette année et puis la tournée
continue jusque juin 2023 moi je
viendrai te voir en décembre merci à
vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo je vous
mets toutes les infos dans la
description prenez soin de vous et
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner parce que
ça fait plaisir en fait et ça ça vous
coûte rien plutôt pratique et je vous
dis à très bientôt ciao